vous maxime vous aimeriez faire votre
demande en mariage comment quand et
comment alors lors d'un petit week-end
dans un château fort va vous en château
un téléfilm week end voile et char on
espère que le pont le vivace koster
également avec la petite bague qui va
bien au bon moment et à la fin d'un
repas avec la cerise sur la gâteau qui
va avec la cerisaie de kafka reste bien
souvent le gâteau alors vous avez déjà
sait aussi que vous êtes en couple ça
commence à être
j'essaie de trouver le scénario adéquat
non vraiment pourquoi pas vraiment vie
de marié ouais je sais j'ai fait
tellement de mariage tous à tous cette
organisation pourrait l'envoyer plein de
barbie ne fasse pas pour ça que veulent
plus important c'est d'avoir le bon dj
ça c'est hyper non la bonne femme
surtout aussi aussi les deux sont
importants il faut pas précipiter les
choses
bien sûr ça fait combien de temps que
vous êtes presque un an et demi non à ça
commence à faire un essai julia roberts
sur eux mêmes la même sur le gard lozère
et robert bien sûr et est ce que vous
allez nous invité au mariage a bien sûr
fait passer de la famille tout le monde
n a certainement pas tout le monde voilà
je préfère les invitations ou les coins
comme cadeau rien du tout moi j'ai tout
ce qu'il faut un profil qui vous assurer
que ces branches etc et sans condition
la commision à l'éleveur